depuis le début du mois chaque fin de
semaine nous avons présenté des centres
de loisirs installé près de chez vous
pour le dernier relais de cette série
nous irons ce soir dans une base qui
connaît quelques problèmes celle de
créteil jean claude et jacques
s'étendant sur une superficie de 43
hectares la base de créteil est la seule
base de loisirs existantes dans le val
demain les équipements mis à disposition
du public sont des plus complets 30
optimiste 25 420 soit un total de plus
de 100 d'embarcations pédalos et barques
comprise
une surveillance y est exercée en
permanence en effet n'est pas rare
d'enregistrer sur ce plan d'eau des
vents de force 6 à 7 pour les débutants
une école de voile dispense des cours
théoriques qui leur permettent de
prendre la mer après une heure
d'enseignement seulement
une grande absence sur cette base la
pratique de la planche à voile
déconseillée par un arrêté préfectoral
un examen de l'école normale supérieure
de zoologie a en effet révélé dans ce
lac un haut degré de pollution le plan
d'eau a été aménagé sur une ancienne
sablière ainsi les zoophiles 30
entretiennent une pollution quasi
permanente à cela vient s'ajouter le
branchement sauvage d'égout sur deux
bouches d'alimentation doute pour
l'instant cette pollution est égale à
10% du volume des eaux du lac mais ce
chiffre ne peut aller qu'en augmentant
si la préfecture et les services
municipaux peuvent agir sur la deuxième
cause en revanche la première raison
pourrait à long terme condamner
l'existence de cette base quoi qu'il en
soit la création d'une piscine d'eau
traitée évite tous les dangers pour les
baigneurs éventuelles